bin ich voll gegen diese kante gelaufen
von der tür und bin richtig weg geflogen
und hatte eine krasse
gehirnerschütterung
er wollte etwas klappt herz bekommen
beim neuen video ja für heute habe ich
mir natürlich mal wieder ihr wisst
bescheid wie immer was ganz spezielles
überlegt heute ist es wirklich mal was
ganz spezielles und zwar habe ich
letztens irgendwo auf youtube ein video
gesehen da hat irgend so ein typ seine
alte schule gezeigt und da hab ich
gedacht ich erinnere mich noch so gut an
meine grundschulzeit und meine
grundschule deshalb fast um die ecke
jetzt regnen heute und 12 zu fuß im
gefängnis gehört wieder ein bisschen
jetzt auch scheißegal wir ziehen das
jetzt trotzdem durch und zwar haben wir
uns aufgelaufen sind hierhin gedüst mit
unserem porsche ja und wir steigen jetzt
einfach mal gleich aus diesem
wunderhübschen auto aus und ich zeige
euch mal was hier so früher abgänge in
unserer fußball das war wirklich krass
wir haben ihre pokémon karten getauscht
wir haben uns geklappt und so weiter
deswegen paar alte erinnerungen wieder
ausgraben es hat sich vieles verändert
irgendwie ist das schade finde ich aber
ist halt so solche die den job machen
davon überhaupt hin offen im jahr das
ist meine schule war meine alte
grundschule also hier war ich von der
bahn waren hier erste bis vierte klasse
von der ersten bis vierten klasse und
ich erinnere mich an diese zeit noch
besser als an meine fünfte klasse fällt
mir so oder ist doch scheißegal auf
jeden fall wollte ich euch mal diese
diesen spot zeigen
der dollar ist mir immer noch im
gedächtnis als wäre es gestern passiert
ehrlich wir haben immer früher kannst du
einmal so rum zeigen
janina früher sondern gezockt das haben
wir selber erfunden das hieß wie ist das
hin und her laufen und zwar eher sollte
man das ziel den anderen zug zu patchen
so kalt darf dann immer alle leute dann
gab es einen finger und man muss immer
auf die andere seite laufen und was mir
natürlich passiert ist da war dieses
teilen noch nicht da und zwar war dieses
teil war hier früher nicht da war keine
ahnung gegen die klasse und wir haben
dieses spiel gezockt und diese tür die
war früher das war eine andere
ja und ich schon da gelaufen bin richtig
schnell gelaufen und habe einfach so
nach hinten gekippt und hier gilt ein
nein ich mag ihn also irgendwie hat die
tür aufgemacht und ich bin voll wirklich
volk weiß ich auch wahrscheinlich bin
ich voll gegen diese kante gelaufen von
der tür und bin richtig weggezogen hat
eine krasse gehirnerschüttung und ich
habe ohne scheiß fünf jahre später
erfahren dass ein guter freund von mir
die tür damals geöffnet hat der wird es
fünf jahre später hat er das gesagt
witzig oder also da war ich eigentlich
nie ne wir waren immer dahin da war der
fußballplatz zeigt man da also
fußballplatz das war einfach da waren
zwei striche auf dem boden und den zaun
das war es eigentlich oder aber ich weiß
noch ganz genau wir waren die kings wir
haben selbst in der zweiten klasse haben
wir die viertklässler hochgenommen
fußball oder nicht ich stell dir mal vor
werden dieses teil schon gehabt damals
wir es wäre locker umgekommen oder du
bei unserem lifestyle damals oder was
auch immer witzig war diese diese
drehscheibe da waren wir immer drauf ich
habe da fast ich bin einmal bin ich
runtergefallen und dieses teil hat sich
gedreht und voll gegen mein ohr ehrlich
mein opa locker zwei wochen lang rot und
blau alles gemischt und diese
tischtennisplatte die wir auch geil weiß
noch der ein aus unserer klasse damals
40 mal drauf geschrieben gesungen
weißt du nicht mehr toten nein nein nein
es war hier keine ahnung wie der hieß
kennwerte ihren kleinen kleinen schuss
wird immer gesungen und wir haben da
immer zusammen hier mit zum ball
gespielt hat mich nicht so ansonsten das
war früher alles schon da und jetzt
kommt mal kurz mit
jetzt zeige ich euch mal so ungefähr wo
unsere vierte klasse war also hier muss
man sich hier ein
das war unsere klasse da ist jetzt die
in unserem damaligen raum ist jetzt
nicht mehr die 4c sondern die klasse
zebras ehrlich herzlich willkommen
hier lernen die zebras geil alter ich
würde ja gern mal rein guckt aber da
muss man einbrechen da hinten das geht
nicht oder so leute hier dieses
viereckige dingsbums mit den zwei
strichen wie ich eben erklärt habt das
war unser fußball frank schade mit kuba
kommt einfach so ein bauunternehmen an
und denkt jetzt der fußballplatz gehörte
das wäre bei uns damals nicht passiert
dass ein paar leute bevor ich euch mein
fahrrad platz zeigen
da war immer die sonderschule also wir
waren immer leute mit den hat mir mal
streiten die kabel mal drüber und
dachten nur weil die 14 und 47 können
wir uns vermöbeln es war immer so dass
auf jeden fall hier
da darf ich mein fahrrad geparkt der
zweite fahrradständer und auf diesem
dach sind warum geklettert von ihr müsst
euch sport bin froh pause ist der ball
27 mal da oben drauf geflogen und
irgendwer musste immer hoch komischer
star kleine runtergefallen ist nicht
meine waren so groß die sind wieder
hochgekommen
man muss es sogar nicht mal du den ball
oft habe ich immer das sagen ich war
klettere einmal der beste kletterer
vorteil deswegen wird der ärger drauf
ach so und da ist die schwimmhalle weiß
noch als hier die ein aus unserer studie
aus unserer klasse ordnung immer die
jetzt ist immer noch rein gegangen hat
dann in ihre frustrationen
da haben wir alle geschrieben wir lassen
wir es lieber lassen wollen wir gar
nicht genauer erwähnt
auf jeden fall wir haben wir auch
fußball gespielt ab und zu und ich weiß
noch ganz genau
jan du ist das ist ein guter freund von
mir schöne grüße an dich der hat einmal
mit seinem software war so richtig nass
folgen die lehrerin so richtig heftig
gegen den kopf und dann war der ball
erst mal weg und er auch keiner wusste
wo er war also auch hier und in diesem
raum waren immer irgendwelche spiel
setzen durfte man immer in der zweiten
großen pause raus kam dann konnte man
damit durch die gegend kommt genau und
das hier war einmal
das war das heftigste karussell das für
klein geworden oder sind es nicht kommen
das war früher
okay das kann auch sein weil ich so groß
war aber dass karima so groß vor das war
einfach krass so weil das war immer
unser karussell ja uns immer heftig
gedreht und passen immer mit dem kopf da
waren wir noch keine reifen drum gegen
diese stangen knallt ab und zu kam der
krankenwagen ehrlich der kam es zwei mal
weiß doch auf jeden fall bei dieser
schaukel
da haben wir mal so hochgeschaukelt und
sind dann runter gesprungen ich weiß
doch keiner jetzt mal runter gesprungen
und ist nicht abgekommen dann ist
herunter oder dingen so voll gegen zwei
auch witzig ja da gibt es auch gar nicht
so zu sagen oder fällt ihr noch hinein
dann würde ich sagen das war's mit dem
video
ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen wenn ihr
auch immer bock habt mein kindergarten
zu sehen es ist ja auch mal krass
projekt oder so so heimlich so weil er
kommt man ja nicht so rein einlass auf
jeden fall meinen daumen nach oben da
bei 15.000 nix machen wir das oder bei
20.000 30 30
keine ahnung bei 17.000 kommt dass auch
das ist das wäre heftig wohl da hab ich
das überhaupt
naja egal ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen
das war meine wunderschöne schule hier
hängen sehr viele erinnerungen dran auch
wenn ich viele vergessen wegen einer
gehirnerschütterung aber gut dass sie
eigene schalter peace